hi everyone I'm Zara Larsen and these
are my favorite snacks
[Music]
these are some of my absolute favorite
snacks they're from the brand
how we would say it in Sweden I'm
definitely
a salty girl like I like Savory stuff
and these are like the premium
what do you guys have that's like oh
Cheetos so good
these ones
lentil chips
[Music]
do you have a way more crunch to them
um they're almost like you know a
regular chip but the texture adds
something to it every Swede have had a
well beer and they kind of branded
Friday coziness we have tacos every
Friday and then we have Olivia and
that's just a part of our culture
that's the way it is and we call it
tacos but it's really a burrito it's
very strange
hey
salt and vinegar place these are very
thin they're not ruffled which salt and
vinegar chips shouldn't be they're very
light
I just love
the exfoliation your mouth gets after a
bag of these
thank you these are cornichons
so
just open it like this oh look they even
had a little pick in there for me
it's a lot of stock
hello I'm really confused out guys
oh it's not it's not a big so I'm just
trying to lift all of these up I know
you can do that sorry I'm gonna put it
back
uh again I'm a savior girl
I don't like things too sweet
this one like I love pickled stuff the
small ones they're just like a little
bit more intense in their flavor I love
love love these
so nice and salty
thank you
it's knickers baby
just classic and I feel like they did
such a good job with their commercial
like you're not yourself when you're
hungry
and the Snicker can save the day I just
think it's like the perfect candy bar
I love and I just feel like my blood
sugar levels they're up the thing with
Swedish people when we eat candy we buy
everything in really small pieces and
then we throw it down in one bag and we
just call it La school days which is
like loose candy where you would take
like a little bit of this a little bit
of that a little bit of that and then
you would weigh it and then you would
pay for the total amount you know if I
would have Snickers I would get like the
mini ones and they would be part of my
bigger bowl of candy so these are some
of my favorite snacks but you guys have
also asked me to talk about some classic
Swedish snacks so let's bring them in
a real Classic this is kind of like a
mini bag of loose candy in a way because
you have all these different ones you
know in one bag like a Haribo classic I
would do this I would take the orange I
would take the green the yellow and you
just mix them all together like this
um full
spectrum of flavor
in America like we we are big fans of
Swedish Fish there are fish sometimes in
in this package as well what do you
think of like the American style Swedish
fish can I have a look at them
yeah we have some parties
we have this in Sweden
it actually reminds me a little bit of
of these red ones
it's a dupe
or this one well I feel like they're
very similar and the consistency the
texture the flavor they're okay you know
they're okay but they're not
representing the huge variety of candy
that we have and that I am quite
proud of weirdly enough
yeah dime I really really thought this
was an international thing that
everybody in the whole world loved
the thing with me I love to like undress
it so instead I'ma show you I do this
so you kind of take the chocolate off
and then you only have this like hard
caramel part if you aren't allergic to
nuts
there's just no way that you won't love
this I was wondering if there was one
like Swedish phrase you think every
should know
let's [__] go
so we have
crisp bread can I get bread this is a
classic like breakfast it's so yummy
it's so good you would put like just a
piece of turkey or ham on top of it you
can even have callus caviar which I love
it's salty it's creamy it's um yeah
cream smoked row which sounds amazing
honestly some people they do this
[Music]
I think it's a little too much I like to
do this
maybe like
yeah maybe like that much for the whole
sandwich because this is this is strong
like
if you want to eat this it's kind of
like you have to brush your teeth after
oh thank you
these are blood cars and it's funny
because their slogan is Sweden's most
bought car
and it's true
this is just like a marshmallow candy
and with these ones I have to do this
together
and then I can eat them that's just how
you do it yeah
that's just the thing
almost who's in the background they're
nodding
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for watching me talk
about and eat some of my favorite snacks
and talk about some Swedish snacks it if
you want to listen to my music
I have my single can Tamer out right now
and I will release an album very very
soon so thank you for watching
[Music]
[Applause]